thousands of turkish women are expected
to protest later today against turkey
leaving an international convention on
violence against women
human rights groups say that the move
sends quote a reckless and a dangerous
message
to perpetrators and has set turkey back
on women's rights
i'll be speaking with a human rights
lawyer about the situation in turkey in
just a moment but first
this report she looks anxiously out the
window
are there any suspicious cars parked out
front is anyone standing by the entrance
this is janzu urki's daily routine the
31 year old and her son
rarely leave their apartment in the
western turkish city of bolu anymore
not since receiving death threats from
her own husband
i'm going to kill all of you
i will slaughter you with a blunt knife
the kid stays with me
[Music]
continuously receives threats like this
and she knows he means every word
before she left him he had abused her
for years
he even beat her mother the police did
nothing apart from
advising jhansu to seek protection at a
women's shelter
meanwhile her abuser feels perfectly
safe
he told me if i kill you i'll go to
prison for three years
but that won't stop me after three years
i'll be back
jansu doesn't believe the turkish state
will protect her
instead she's turned to the public on
turkish media she's spoken out against
her abuser
and the turkish authority's failure to
act a bold move
especially now that turkey has withdrawn
from the istanbul convention
protecting women from violence president
erdogan justified this step by
repeatedly claiming that the convention
served to spread western notions of
emancipation
we will not let foreigners influence the
way we deal with the issue
we have our own historical and cultural
ways
we will not allow the safety of our
families to be jeopardized
these women are demanding the protection
of their families too
but in a different way than edelwan
envisioned they are pressuring
turkey to respect the international
agreement
in the past year 300 women were murdered
and another 117 women died
due to unknown causes
[Applause]
now turkish women are fighting back
literally
more and more women are signing up for
self-defense courses like these
here krav maga an israeli martial art is
being taught
the women in this class have had enough
of violence and harassment from men
the course leader has observed mostly
young women in her group
more and more 25 to 35 year old women
come
to us not all participants have
experienced physical violence
some just want to know how to react to
[Music]
harassment
has found another way to protect herself
she's installed a security door in her
apartment to prevent her abusive husband
from breaking in
but she knows if he's determined to kill
her he will
he told me himself he said look uncle
erdogan has withdrawn from the istanbul
convention protecting women
so we can kill as many women as we want
without being punished
the istanbul convention should continue
to be respected in our country
it was the only thing that deterred men
[Music]
growing solidarity among women in turkey
is also acting as a deterrent
jhansu experienced an outpour of support
after she made her case public
since then the threats against her and
her family have stopped
and let's get more on this we are joined
now by tom articano suze
a human rights lawyer with the ngo
equality now
welcome to the program and thank you for
joining us as we've heard the turkish
government says it doesn't need the
convention
because the country's laws protect women
what's your reaction
hello thanks so much for having me in
this program
well the withdrawal from the istanbul
convention
is a very negative step and it indeed
undermines the protection of women from
violence in turkey
turkey indeed has a legal framework that
protects women from violence
but that legal framework is not adequate
it requires a lot of improvement to make
sure that
women are protected from all forms of
violence not only on paper
but in real life and the monitoring
mechanism of the istanbul convention
graveyard
in 2018 flagged
a number of inconsistencies and a number
of gaps in the legislation of turkey
in its policy judicial practice and
procedures
failing to protect women against
violence and now with this move or
withdrawing from the convention
turkey sends a powerful message to the
world
that women's rights are already well
protected
under a local framework in turkey it
does not require any improvement it does
not require
taking any additional measures which is
indeed true and and we just saw i mean
to illustrate also your point of course
we just saw in that report the husband
of
of the woman explicitly referring to
turkey's withdrawal
from the istanbul convention saying it
was essentially a green light for for
him to to kill her
in fact what do you think when you hear
stories like that
well this situation clearly demonstrates
that the situation of women's rights and
violence against women in turkey which
is already very worrying
not not will not only improve
but it will worsen and the persons who
are responsible
for protecting women from violence
people in the government people in the
law enforcement
will indeed rely on the withdrawal of
turkey from the istanbul convention
as the evidence of the lack of political
will
of the government to provide sufficient
support to women
and it will indeed encourage the
perpetrators
it does send a message to perpetrators
that
violence against women is not a
significant issue
it's not a human rights violation and
the abusers will
indeed enjoy widespread impunity
for years there has already been
a large-scale impunity of perpetrators
for who committed violence against women
in turkey
and it's particularly depressing that
the situation
will only worsen because of the move of
the government of turk to israel from
the women's rights convention
i i have to ask you then um in in that
context
um you know we have heard that that
there is a protest for example that is
planned for today um a lot of women also
taking self-defense into their own hands
we've seen those illustrations in your
opinion
what can be done to push back against
the erosion of women's rights what
should be done right now
i think what should be done in turkey
and
around the world is that we should all
stand
in solidarity with the women in turkey
who are protesting against turkish
withdrawal from the istanbul convention
and we do need to stop the movement
of widespread backlash against istanbul
conventions that
not only originated in turkey but
in other parts of the world other
countries of the council of europe
there are far right conservative groups
and forces
who are interested in not
asking impunity for violence against
women and we should counter this
narrative and myths and stereotypes
surrounding istanbul convention which
are not true thank you so much for
joining us tom mar de cano sid say from
equality now we appreciate it
thank you thanks a lot
you